all right I think we got in
I hope
hope it's uh all working
so weirdly the um
game was up
before nine o'clock today in which you
could actually queue into uh we hit Q at
about 8 55 850 it had a 48 minute q but
then it accelerated pretty quickly
um so I think we're all good uh we ran a
poll yesterday
on which class to play between the druid
and the
necromancer
to which people picked the Necromancer
so
uh so if you did if you played closed
beta you would have had your characters
from last week and your items from last
week if you're just starting open beta
for the first time then you obviously
don't have any characters
but I'll be checking chat on YouTube and
um twitch so you can play Druid and
necro you can basically play all five
classes this week this week is Druid and
necro I think we're going necro because
of the community pool that we did
yesterday I actually really wanted to
try Druid but here we are so let's get
into it I know people are waiting and
watching can you change the difficulty
when we want uh I didn't try in the game
OD but I um
I just did it based off of uh
like I did veteran mode because
it seemed it's not that bad to be honest
whoa that's kind of I'm just gonna go
with one of the presets
instead
uh you could play hardcore I'm not going
to
uh
it's a boring name uh I can't even I
don't know
you can't even think of a name uh
uh we'll just do my
last name
so here you can pick your cheers World
tears I'm gonna go World tier two uh
just for more experience more gold it's
a little bit more challenging but not
too bad so let's get going
I know people
wanna see the action
Sanctuary
I need to switch to change the
resolution there's a refuge so I'll fix
that in a second sorry heavens and the
burning Hells
instead
it became a new Battleground in this
eternal conflict
a secretive group called The haradrim
has kept Mortals safe
but now we're swamps powerful order is a
ask of what it was
sanctuaries ancient creators have
returned to claim the hearts of
humankind
this is the story of their downfall
[Music]
should be able to Quest with other
people OD if you find them I think you
can like
inspect and or try to play with them so
it's possible uh World we're playing on
PC
but I need to change the resolution on
my uh on the game
[Music]
and I got excited that we got in so
quickly
[Music]
okay
got a Toyota just letting the custom
play out in case people didn't see it
last week
[Music]
foreign
the other benefit to
um I should find better shape last week
is batteries oh
oh that's right okay the other benefit
of playing last week is that I have
skills already because like you get them
from Renown and um all that stuff so I
actually get to be slightly ahead I was
like why do I have I guess maybe you
also get ray skeleton off the bat for
necro because you don't get any skills
normally if you start from zero
uh I don't know what's good Hemorrhage
person enemy
pose
uh let's go for bone splinters we can
always change this pretty easily so
it's fine I will raise the skeleton oh
we can't raise a skeleton obviously The
Necromancer need to kill something
then we'll raise one
I don't know the corpse the corpse stuff
looks a lot better than in the past also
it only looks like the cut scenes are
showing the black bars on the side so
maybe I'll just leave it
also I feel weirdly sure it's probably
because I'm not supposed to have this
skill yet
I'm gonna say this this beginning part
shouldn't be this easy
um but hey here we are
with two skills already and what I mean
by that if you guys are curious is um
as you get through um
fractured Peaks you'll get uh you'll do
different things and get renowned and
then as you get renowned and do these
things you'll get you know bonus skill
points potion charges Etc so
hopefully the audio is better this week
too because I think we we uh adjusted
the mic and all that stuff so everywhere
that girl and Jordan are supposed to be
S tier according to the closed beta
folks but
uh just so you know and Demi uh and
Rohan I had a 48 minute queue but then
it accelerated pretty quickly it went
from like 48 to 15 minutes so
um
I would say like it's it's definitely
better than last week last week was
pretty tough madman just stumbled into
town and Gabriel says you can change the
difficulty on statues you find in the
map
what is he talking about
come I'll explain
all right
the the the minion looks pretty good too
compared to like dude if you need to
compare that to Diablo 2 or Diablo 3
even
my man's is glowing and he's got a
helmet
[Music]
for necro what do you build
I don't know yet you know new game hard
to say evil is gathering strength in the
I don't know man you always just build
crit hitting crit damage right
and then just like be tanky have like
stamina and all that fun stuff uh we'll
just like level bone Splinter all the
way we'll see what's better has a 20
chance
to make animals enemies vulnerable or
hitting the same enemy at three times
with the same cast of uh yeah what's it
called Critical Strike chance as we just
joked about
can you do more than one
uh we'll find out
I don't think it says how many you can
oh maximum four all right
I should probably pick up that buckler
look at my tattered Shield it's got
holes in it
all right uh it's the same this buckler
is the same
I mean like look at my skeletons
compared to the normal skeletons in the
ground
I would save minor uh
much uh stronger and Netflix
aesthetically pleasing
we are leveling at a very quick clip all
right we can get into second tier so you
got bone spear a classic bloodlance
that's new
blood surge
blight
sever
oh man I'm tempted it I want to try
something new even though bone Spears is
such a classic uh let's throw a
bloodlance why not let's try that
uh it's so weird Slayer So like
um the game was up before 9 00 a.m
Pacific today meaning that they like
kind of hedged and they like knew that
like people were gonna be queuing so
like they almost like started the queue
before just like 9am like they did last
week to probably alleviate problems they
had last week so far it's smooth I don't
want to jinx it we might get kicked at
some point hopefully we don't get back
in Cube but they did you know come
Saturday Sunday during the closed uh
Early Access
um it got a lot better Thursday and uh
or sorry Saturday and Sunday were were
great like it was like one minute queue
times Friday was the one that was pretty
bad but you know uh Rod Ferguson came
out um I think in a euro gamer article
and he kind of said you know the reason
why they built in cues is you know not
not only just because of the server load
but also because during those times
they're they're troubleshooting and so
they'll always add more time to the
queue as they're trying to like
basically fix the game in real time
um but we'll see how the open Beta holds
up because there's gonna be a lot more
people this week obviously playing the
game
um you know on multiple consoles too not
just on a PC which is what we're playing
on today
um but so far oh we haven't used this
skill here
yeah
that doesn't look as cool as my bone my
uh bone splinters but uh this is the
bloodlance there
also um because we played last week I'm
gonna be able to put some some gear on
uh once we get to kyova Chad which is
the main first town you get into
um which should make things a bit
quicker so we will probably be able to
level up pretty quickly uh which is nice
and then I know like also if I don't
know if there's any returning viewers
from last week but everyone was saying
oh it's kind of feels slow and
um you know that's how it's always going
to be in the arpg when you have like no
gear and you don't have um any like
uh skills and all that stuff yet but I
will tell you by 25 it pretty much it
pretty ramps up pretty quickly I can't
speak but um it's pretty fun and if you
want to see some like level 25 Rogue
stuff we can do that I have a level 25
sorceress as well
um
sorry saying that they wish they had the
monk in here
um if you like the melee combat of Monk
I would say try the melee version of
Rogue it's um kind of similar in a way
um the only downside is I haven't tried
like all the tanky stuff that a monk
could do you know with Cyclone strike
and like all that stuff but in terms of
like
the kind of like frenetic fast-paced
close kind of quick action
um the Rogue might give you that
um well GS coverage include patch notes
analysis in the future
um we generally do that in news or we'll
report on the news in terms of the
patches we don't necessarily always Deep
dive on the patch notes
um but you know if there's interest and
people are enjoying our Diablo streams
you know I'm a very I'm an avid fan I've
been since you know Diablo 1 that was
kind of like one of my first games
um as a kid playing on PC shout out to
my cousin Vincent who is not going to
hear this but he was the one who
actually showed me Diablo one way back
in the day as well as like Wing
commander and like Warcraft so I owe it
to my cousin really
um who got me into PC gaming
um and Diablo one was so fun because
like you know for anyone that played I I
learned how to do that you know the
potion dupe and it was just like having
fun duping things and like you know
destroying monsters and demons and staff
of apocalypse and King sort of haste and
all that fun stuff but uh
yeah we might not do deep Dives in the
the patch analysis but we'll definitely
be streaming the game when it's out and
you know if it's something that people
enjoy maybe it's something we do weekly
or
maybe I can sneak it in as like a like a
lunch stream or something I have 31 to
33 minutes yeah I mean just wait um if
you're lucky like I was earlier maybe it
accelerates
um it wasn't like a true one-to-one like
it was last week last week was very much
whatever your
um timer was that's what it was uh don't
forget Baldur's Gate that's a good call
Richard I
full honesty here I did not play
Baldur's Gate Baldur's Gate 3 is coming
out though which is uh I believe this
year I forget I think it's in June or
August I don't remember exact date but
um it's coming out this year which is
cool I know a lot of people are excited
for that one
um being done by the fine folks at Larry
in studios we've done the Duke Divinity
original sin oh also please tell me if
the gameplay audio is like too loud for
you guys um this is kind of the first
encounter some of the uh beta sound
effects are kind of like loud so it
might be a little bit
spicy so tell me if it is and if it is
we'll try to adjust for it
okay that was way easier than normal
only because we we're geared right now
all right sorry we have those three we
have those extra skills right now so
um that's that's kind of why
also
um
Let's see we could enhance our
bloodlance it pierces through enemies or
do you guys want to see more skills we
can also just not like
I think it's good to synergize your
skills but you know if you want to see
more stuff then we can do other stuff
um
because I don't I've never I don't know
I didn't get to go play necro and close
beta so I don't know much about this
class
for now just keep going down the chain
and then we'll uh see what folks say or
think
yeah Coda hey you got the whole weekend
I say try um if you have if you have a
preference from what you've played
before I can kind of maybe give you some
guidance in terms of like who might fit
your play style but really the open Beta
is there they they made it so that you
could change all your skills like really
easily
um oh oh it's a two-hander okay gotcha
okay um you can you can easily refund
your skills so you know you can try each
class and get through the skills pretty
good um
truly but yeah
Michelle can't wait to try the necro
Gonna Save Druid for release yeah like I
mean
try all the all the characters you want
there's a level cap at 25.
they want to get me drunk
[Music]
does the sork have the Wizards beam uh
yes enterblade uh something similar not
like a beam but they have something
called incinerate which basically does
something very similar
um Jackson my PC is not a great like
anything crazy it's got like a i7
um I think 13 7 13 700 in it or yeah and
then like a 20 80 super so nothing crazy
in this one um just at home right now
yeah
I think they made it so that you could
play it across a wide range of stuff so
I don't think it needs too too much 26
minutes for Zach hey those cute times
folks for those that weren't here last
week that's nothing compared to last
week some people were saying 60 Minute Q
times 80 minute Q times last week so
this is like you know
[Music]
Alex I'm not sure uh necro necro seems
fun so far uh nicker seems really strong
uh as well will H is saying I like I
said earlier I heard from someone that
was playing close beta that necro and
Druid are apparently s tier
um but we'll have to see
I'm tempted to that see if you use VP
yeah I think it's butter I guess it is
actually but I mean it's still like two
years old I think
all right I'm skipping this I'm sorry
y'all let's go let's go let's go fight
let's do some things
we are
uh
again I just want to say we have that
extra skill which is like helping us
quite a bit so if it seems like I'm
leveling really fast it's
that's part of why
um
that was all of them
all right
Bloodlines eight times your next cast of
Bloodlines is guaranteed overpower
overpower is apparently really strong
well at least 800 degrees or a boss are
affected by bloodlands you're getting 15
attack speed
huh
is pretty good
let's do that because getting eight
eight times eight times cast seems kind
of long mad man
Crusader and monk were best hey I'm with
you Christian I was a monk main D3 and
then I was a I was a Pally in D2 for the
most part
Crusader was fun too
um
once it there was like a certain build
that I really liked with Crusader
um in D3 once they kind of got more set
items out and stuff a lot yeah well they
said last weekend's uh start a beta 70
minute plus easy yeah they must have fed
them to me
yeah open Beta this week free for
everyone to try don't need a pre-order
this week um compared to last week last
week early access was pre-ordered
they kept it locked up for a reason
the key might be on that woman who is
leading them
it's got the chapel key okay
knock on wood chat last time we were
doing this stream I
um that's weird I uh
got to this specific cut scene in the
chapel we finished the cut scene and
then I got booted I'm gonna really pray
here funny because it's Chapel
um that we don't get kicked
good luck to us
[Music]
first timer tips
um if it's first timer don't play
veteran you know just like enjoy your
experience
I would say synergize your skills or
just try things if you want and then you
can refund pretty easily
um
other than that just have fun I think on
on non-veterate mode you shouldn't have
too much issue really
uh if the black borders on the side
bother people later tell me because I
can change the resolution but it seems
to only be doing it on the cinematics
it's because I'm in um like a windowed
mode that's that's probably why so don't
think it's because of the game it's
totally my own resolution
I'm gonna shut up during this uh
cutscene because it's like advancement's
been pretty good
shameful
our father has granted you a path to
Salvation
and yet you stray from it
every opportunity
drink
and Gamble
covet
and steal
shameful
yeah
or source with Hydra is really good
[Music]
the Lords of hell are coming to devour
our world
put in the light
safe
has taught you to deny your heart's
desire
and turned you into a prisoner
within yourself
break the chains
and discover
who you were meant to be
break the chain
s and be beautiful
in sin
Kieran the timers are going quicker this
week than last week so if at minimum
it's whatever it says but it might
accelerate
money
I brought your child into this world
thank you
[Music]
have a
white mother
the first
go to the dry steps
and continue your
now our true work begins
uh butter Golem the uh that cinematic is
basically the equivalent of your kind of
in-between acts they've done a really
good job of weaving these cinematics
throughout your story playthrough so
you'll see a bunch of these as you play
through it like on on kind of like the
major story beats which is like really
nice and cool
um is that Franklin with a good tip on
the uh you collapse on capping your
frame rate to not like fry any 3080s
there's also a Nvidia patch yesterday
that came out for Diablo 4 which should
also help
um well Karen the queue time if it's
long it's it should be one to one if not
better as I mentioned earlier so you
should just wait it out don't leave just
wait it out and then you'll get in just
like I did earlier I had a 48 minute
queue that like all of a sudden I looked
back and it was like 16 minutes so
help them
cool Joey we talking care again
mommy Lilith
it cannot be
I must report to the cathedral
listen there is a Hermit to the
Northeast
you have to remember though that this is
this is beta I also haven't seen the end
of an ax scene butter so like I I don't
know if it looks different than what we
saw there also you're watching it
through a stream if you if it's on your
PC it's gonna look a lot better than
what you saw on the stream it's just
always gonna be the case it looks it it
looks good
um I'll say that
all right we're moseying on here we're
just absolutely gonna oh oh These are
these are good too you're going to want
to find these there's 28 in the Justice
first opening area
um you basically get free stats in like
HP and different things from it um so if
you see those always click them although
weirdly like why would why are we
clicking on an altar of Lilith when
she's like the bad person but yeah
yeah all right these are the smaller
dungeons
oh yeah our attack speed does go up
pretty much all right
uh smaller dungeons just has one Elite
um
all right
different shrines now
uh this is a necro thanks enerblade and
uh to the question that talks burrito
ass
I do want to play Jude though
uh apparently
the reason why I like the Druid is
um could be pretty strong or you know
according again to some closed beta
folks is that
they have items that basically
make
um your shape-shifting form and your
like Elemental form like count as the
same thing if that makes sense and so
basically if you have like an earth
skill and a wear bear skill and it says
that like you know your where Bearer now
counts as Earth that means like it's
basically doing
you're getting double the benefit right
so everything that's like you know
enhancing your wear bear stuff is
enhancing your earth like that's my
understanding of it um but haven't tried
it so can't say for a certain but that
does sound very strong if it if it is
that way because you're basically
getting double benefit which is kind of
uh this is new if you all didn't know
there's um you know
well I don't know if it's new I guess I
guess it is from the standpoint of like
we didn't gather materials this way we
used to have to like
you know slay demons and whatnot there's
like ore as well on top of these herbs
the herbs help you make elixirs and it's
also used to upgrade your potion
um at The Alchemist and then or and all
that stuff helps you do upgrades for
like your armors and all that fun stuff
uh Coda says can't wait four to five
minutes
nice nice
um for all those that didn't know this
has been you know I could be jinxing it
but way more smooth sailing this week
they've done uh some really good work uh
since last week to make this um
definitely not uh laggy like last week
or sorry not laggy but uh where there's
Syracuse
is there a warrior type uh and any tips
or maybe like me Jason there is it's a
barbarian but as myself and chat
mentioned earlier right now Barbarian is
probably like it's fun but it's if
you're talking about power in terms of
like the classes it's probably the
lowest on the totem pole and like it it
might be harder because it's melee which
means that like you know for some of
these bosses you're gonna have to be up
close and and personal I
want to say Rogue range so Rogue might
be a nice in-between because you can
play like the The Distance game with a
bow or up close with melee
um or Source uh sorcerer sorceress is
pretty good too because once you get
Hydra you can just put down Hydra and
hydrate like it owns a lot of things
um when I say range is a little bit
easier maybe to start only because you
can kind of like kite or kiting meaning
that like you can you know shoot them
from far away click away keep running
shoot click run you know click shoot
click run Etc
um but if you're looking for just a pure
warrior class uh Jason it's either
Barbarian or melee Rogue right now
but melee Rogue is a little bit tougher
in the beginning when you don't have as
many items
as will mentioned yeah easier probably
easier better experience to start if
you're not playing a warrior class
because it it
she was banished a little harder right
now I would say just a little bit not
only on certain things but I think if
you if you play a non-veteran you'll
probably be fine and it's probably all
the same
it was prophesied she would come
and come what does she want
that's the question
Sanctuary is old Dante had a lot of fun
with the sorcerer last week yeah super
good I never got the um double Hydra
legendary but that thing is that thing
is strong
serves neither side
has started
we are playing in it right now you can
get you can get in now to download and
queue
but you two share a connection Mark
loving the Rogue as well yeah I played a
melee Rogue I didn't get um a good bow
but like I think he could still find out
no problem
good Zach I'm excited for you we're in
this together
what are you gonna play for a second
uh enerblade yeah Druid and Neko are
unlocked um they weren't in the first
test they're now in open beta
uh Jester those two new classes are the
or well they're not new classes more so
that you can play them this weekend
um and you couldn't last weekend so
that's why we're checking out necro
um you know if we have any time later uh
we can try to show off the Druid too but
you'll see this opening area which is
kind of like tutorially so you guys
might not want that from me you probably
just want to see more necro I want to
get the corpse explode because I think
corpse explode is really strong
always has been
you gotta play Neko nice nice enjoy that
gloves better yes I think no
uh here's some of the ore that I
mentioned
let me pick some of that up
and because I have aspects which I'll
tell you guys about in a second
um aspects or things you get from
dungeons
which you can then imprint on your on
your uh darn it on your gear and then uh
you can basically make your like good
rare or it doesn't even have to be good
your your um
you can make your your rares into
legendaries basically
all right hold on you guys are gonna
lose audio for a second uh
put that user in a timeout when he
learns that Lilith is here blood will
flow
they are ancient enemies uh I don't know
X screen if it's boring to you then you
know it's early uh it's not the whole
game secondly the game doesn't he says
the game doesn't look like you it it
does if you look at someone put someone
posted a screenshot of D3 versus D4
there's a pretty big difference but also
like D3 wasn't as dark but still like if
you just look at character models and
things like that it's very different to
enter the city we have no time for this
uh yeah there was someone in chat I
removed them
that's why you lost audio for a second
because I I got I had to click away out
of the game to get rid of them
you must perform a cleansing ritual yes
yes
I will I will I will grab this thing uh
uh anger
get rid of that
threw it in the fire
but you know I I've played every Diablo
you know I'm gonna play this one too
gonna have fun like you know helps at my
friends also play so that's another
reason we got to do the boss fight last
week which is
um
fun was able to complete it once and
fail on the other other time only
because we failed the second time
because me and my friend were under
leveled and there weren't that many
people there compared to the first one
we did
um but now I kind of understand the boss
better so we are rubber banding the
town's a little let's see if the town
got better last week was kind of run off
to the dry steps in search of that Pale
Man from your vision
I must know
what party plays in all this
but
dream something finished my negotiations
emergent in the center of the city has
it just tell him I sent you
[Music]
oh nice uh King have you played any of
the other like arpgs like
this and just made it to this console
and like it did its last like or it did
a big update I played a little bit of
wool sick when it came out
um but I haven't haven't gone back
uh Christian am I enjoying the necro so
far yeah but to your point also not the
class I would I would probably play okay
all right come on can we get back in
game or are we screwed
up here comes the error codes ladies and
gentlemen
yeah
all right we jinxed it
wow that's pretty cool you can woojo I
know he's a a big Diablo streamer
um
you can TP back to down and back to a
boss to get a new instance and then you
end up killing four bosses in five
minutes that's kind of nuts
no wasn't good I only played a little
bit better okay I think we are gonna
have to exit
sadly
and then come back in which means that
we're gonna have to recue because I
don't think I mean I've never gotten
through once a disconnect happened where
like
we're on the screen it'll basically
leave you on the screen
D3 release yeah it was worse last week
although who knows all right we're we're
doing it
um
I I'm so sorry y'all I don't know what
how long the queue is gonna be
I really don't
um you're gonna have to bear with me
hopefully it's not too bad but it could
easily be like a 40 40 minute Q or
something
um
the town the town has the town was a
little bit more like rough in the uh you
know like probably because there's more
people and stuff but like it's fine it's
a beta it's gonna happen let's find out
let's find out what happens here as you
see a giant mess behind me sorry y'all
kids birthday tomorrow got a lot of
packages in
all right hope for me that it's like sub
okay 18 minutes hey chat we can live
with 18 minutes that is ah that is
nothing here I'll I'll come back to you
I'll chat with you all 18 minutes is is
nothing compared to last week we are we
are cruising we are cruising I love
seeing 18 minutes not even not even not
even mad about it
not even mad uh but I do hope um the
folks that got in uh you're enjoying it
you know if you have any issues like me
exit out like I just did get back into
queue and you'll get back in
uh we got to play
what like 20 30 minutes there before we
got booted
um so not terrible
not terrible
yeah 18 minutes is worth right world I
mean anyone that played last week knows
like 18 minutes is worth
um
never played before is it hard or should
I start playing uh Rogue Fox I don't
think it's particularly hard I don't
even think veterans that hard to be
honest uh so
I say give it a shot it it it's very
friendly right like I think
weirdly like once this game once Diablo
3 went to console I was like yeah
this is this is now entering that
territory where it's gonna be for
everybody right and that's why they have
all the diff the tier difficulties and
and things like that is for scaling
right for for wide audience so check it
out
um
you've been stuck at six minute Q for 20
minutes now well that's not so great
well I just moved to 16 that's good
uh Dante says curious to see how long
your queue is well not bad right
I think they should start limiting uh
the amount of characters you encounter
in your town because I think that is
where the lag comes into play I think so
too Dante but remember this is a beta
stress test for them so they probably
want to see all this happen right they
want is they wanna
test how many people they can probably
have in a town and like you know all the
people teleporting back to town and all
that stuff
um
but like but last Saturday and Sunday it
was totally fine like it'll it'll do
some kind of like rubber banding
sometimes in town but like for the most
part Saturday Sunday was like pretty
smooth and clean
um three like I said like sub three
minute cues if that there were times
where there wasn't any cue
um uh AV says why such long wait times
first time playing Diablo um
one is a beta two it's like a stress
test for their servers basically three
it's open Beta meaning it's free and
everybody can play so everyone's trying
to hop on and you know some of the
comments that like the developers made
like Rod Ferguson included
um they said you know sometimes they'll
have cues and increase queue times
because they are you know fixing things
in the background as like in real time
so
you know wanting to make sure that they
can fix it while making sure that like
you know
um they're not like overloading things
at the same time
um you think GB gbg thinks last week is
on one potato server whereas they have
three now I don't I don't think that's
the case because like I said come
Saturday Sunday unless
unless for some reason Saturday Sunday
which I I have my doubts because you
think there'd be more people playing on
the weekend there was less people
playing Saturday Sunday compared to like
Friday right at launch like I don't know
it we'll see
bang Almighty says uh where where bear
Druid for the win
I wanted to play uh uh I really wanted
to play Druid but you know we did a
community poll yesterday uh on YouTube
so thank you to all the folks that voted
on which class to play between the necro
and the Druid which are now available in
this open beta and it was um pretty
unanimous it was like 66 or so uh voting
necro and 33 33 34 voting Druid which
kind of shocked me but I don't know like
Drew did necro for me and D2 and even in
D3 or necro at least I never really
played them I uh in D2 I played Pally
and and Sorkin Amazon and those and then
a little bit of Barb but it was mainly
um
those three that I mentioned first and
then in um D3 it was mainly Monk sork
man did I ever play Barbarian like
barely it's like Monk and sork for me I
think a lot in D3
trying to think
I played Witch Doctor like one season
maybe when it was like really strong
um
and I played Crusader like one or two
seasons two and that was also really
strong
um but I think for the most part I
almost always played like monk sork in
uh
D3 I'll probably go sork honestly first
character D4
um only because
I don't know it just feels like like I
don't I don't think it's gonna be like
D2 where like you want that one farming
class but like I don't know sork always
seems to be like one of the best farming
classes
to it so blasphemy says the Druid
shape-shifting has a nice flow to it and
it looks fun nice nice
virtual says they're 11 minutes away in
the queue nice I'm now 13 minutes from
18 right so
uh yeah slayer I had that earlier where
like I finished my cue I it looked like
it was putting me in and then it put me
into another queue for about one two
minutes and then I got in so
you have not seen wild cue times that's
true Lars uh those are pretty bad when
expansions drop I mentioned that last
week but last week's was pretty bad like
I saw people at 80 minute queue times
last week which is that's that's pretty
rough I'd probably fire down the stream
if it was a 80 minute Q which I haven't
seen yet so far the most I've seen
earlier pre-9 a.m PT when they opened
was 48 minutes but I was as I was
telling Chad it accelerated pretty
quickly Asian Allen thanks Alan time to
die yeah we don't have those anymore the
the num keys
yep you can blame me that it it failed
this is true
um Jester I don't know if Paladin will
make it into this
um
it does make sense though if there's a
paladin slash Crusader type character as
an expansion right like right now we
only know the ones that we have which is
Source sork I'll say sork because
sorcerer sorcerer is Barbarian Druid
necro and Rogue
you can argue Rogue is a hybrid because
it's melee and barbarians melee but
that's only two melee right
and whereas there's like
three to four well I guess Drew is melee
too so maybe not I don't know I don't
know a lot of people want an assassin
but maybe they're gonna they have traps
on the on the Rogue so you're probably
not getting an assassin I imagine
um
maybe it would be some type of like a
monk Crusader Pally type thing or
something
like that
yeah like most of the people in chat
agreeing that like oh no it went up to
20 minutes what happened
no we're at 11.
Diablo you didn't do this last week
uh okay you know what
breathe it in 20 minutes is still okay
because it doesn't compare to last week
we'll see what happens here this is this
is this will be interesting
does it beta have co-op yes but
so it works in two ways Devon if you're
on
console you only need one
like account to well I guess technically
this week it's open so anyone can have
account but like you could do couch
co-op with console as long as you tie
that your your you and your buddy family
whoever's
um Battlenet accounts to that console
then you can couch Co-op
um if you want to co-op on PC then you
each need to have it like installed and
then you know either find each other
through your friends list or you know in
town I think you can also just like or
like in the open area when you see
people you can just like uh there's a
little emote wheel type thing and you
can invite people that way as well
and inspect them and all that stuff
uh what is that how Q Works no it's
definitely not rocket they didn't last
week it wasn't it didn't add time but
like I said last week also most cues at
minimum if you got kicked was like 40
plus minutes at least
um if not 60 or 80. so we'll see you
know as long as I see that well as I say
as long as I see the cue timers go down
and then it went up as long as I see it
keep going down it you know we'll we'll
just keep trying if it gets too long
then we will we'll consider
um
we'll consider you know stopping the
stream if we need to but I have
confidence you know someone else in chat
said you gotta have faith
which we do
um
man I really want to show you guys
some like Rogue gameplay like
uh I might be able to do that actually
if you guys really want it
I could probably pull up like a
one of the video files at like a level
25 Rogue
melee Rogue though
yeah so Slayer you're right you do need
two blizzard accounts tied to no no I I
believe
I didn't actually try it so maybe maybe
it's just it I know that you can couch
Co-op and I know that you can you can
you just need to tie the two blizzard
accounts to your to that console
or maybe to that platform and then you
can play I don't I don't know how it
exactly works because I didn't try it I
just know that it it works in in terms
of couch Co-op and that the way you have
to do that is with like syncing the
Battlenet account to you know platform
slash console
how does D4 compared to D3
um
DeForest storytelling is better than D3
for sure D4 is darker in tones
D4
obviously visual upgrades right like D3
was definitely more like brighter I
would say not so dark right and then it
was a little bit more I wouldn't say
cartoony because that's like not selling
it right but like you know the vibe kind
of if that makes sense I don't I don't
know
I don't know how to explain that one but
man if you if you just look at like you
know character models of like a you know
any other classes that were in both
games and you put them side by side
there's a pretty big difference you know
hell the necro summon it's like it's
like those skeletons that we killed
earlier that had like no glow no armor
like that's like the D3 skeleton and
then you have our skeleton which I look
at full like has a helmet has boots you
know it's glowing
I don't know
um
yeah you want a D4 HBO Max show Pedro
Pascal Pedro Pascal just taking over the
world you go from watching him as Joel
and the last of us and then like
you see him at Mando that's it that's
where me and my wife were we finished
the last of us and it's like oh Mando's
back all right let's watch Amanda oh
right that's Pedro basketball too
uh Alan also saying queue time is going
up and down yeah hopefully mine doesn't
go
doesn't go about 11 then went to 20. now
we're at 13 so we're almost back to
where we were hoping to get in and play
and it'll be seamless but we'll see
welcome to Blizzard games uh during
betas and also when like the games
launch and when expansions launch
like
Almost Do not be shocked right when
Diablo 4 comes out in in June that um
that uh we uh we have some server queue
times
you know at this point it's just anyone
who's played a Blizzard game you just
expect it you just hope that it's not
you know you just hope it's not you know
80 minutes like people were having last
week
good luck to enter they just failed to
log in that's not so great oh message
retracted it's probably gonna fix it
um
what skills am I using I'm using bone
Splinter and bloodlands but I have no
idea if those are like the best skills I
just happened to pick something we could
like I said we could change
um pretty easily you just refund it in
your skill tab
mine just jumped by literally 103
minutes that's worse than when I started
failed to log in I got the same login
error as last week oh Baby error 37 are
we all getting that fun error we're
gonna get air 37s
uh okay people are scaring me now
because they said good luck cause uh
they their people are failing to enter
we'll see we we gotta believe
everyone said they're like you know Goku
Spirit good spirit positive energy
you know send that energy because that's
what we're gonna need
um
all I can say is if you know you you
waited and you got it tried to get in
and it failed you have no choice but to
pop back into queue there literally is
nothing else you can do or there is
something else you could do
um if you don't I mean everyone's eager
to play right now
um
but if you're if you don't want to deal
with this stress or frustration or anger
I'd almost say like you might be better
off waiting until like 12 o'clock one or
sorry in two to three hours 12 o'clock
one o'clock PT
and it'll probably stabilize a bit but
there'll probably still be a cue
um I will say just from experience last
week
later in the day Friday
like late afternoon night time I think
the queue times were pretty short
foreign
you never know right that's a that's a
demo presentation of the unreal 5.2
which was very impressive
um
but I don't know we're still going to be
dealing with video game 2018 video game
issues it's just gonna be the this is
the way I guess uh
maybe some of that you know I don't even
want to say this because it's just gonna
like stoke the flame but you know part
of it is having games that are you know
always online right
um
but this is a way that they're able to
make
changes and updates faster
um
but here we are 10 minutes let's hope
um if we fail to log in
and we hop back into queue and it's
really long there might be some some
thoughts had about what we do
but we won't cross that bridge till we
get there because we are not sending
that energy out in the world
kind of curious if this is happening to
the other streamers as well I don't have
any any of them up but
wouldn't shock me
um
we shall see
oh okay eight minutes
uh someone asked what I was using I
think it was like bone Splinter and
Bloodlines yeah
so I want to get corpse explode
and a sweet sweet Gollum Gollum Gollum
Gollum Golem not Gollum gollums on top
of mine just because of
they had that um
gameplay showcase I think yesterday
D2 necro Max Kelly is the best what's
interesting is you get skelly's for free
I think like you just get a skill
Helen wants me to play Hearthstone BG's
like creparian while we wait no I'm not
I'm not doing that man
what's up Toast Man snap oh snap bit of
time hello yeah
beta killing time
uh we were in for a good little while we
made it past where we got kicked last
week
but almost around the same level we got
kicked out around level four last week
now kicked out at level five so
they fixed uh that problem seems a lot
of people are playing and causing the
long queue yeah probably
um you know there is there's open Beta
you know last week early access was
already pretty
pretty full you know like I imagine open
Beta is only going to be even more full
so not shocking at all that we're kind
of in this uh
in this queue
uh Slayer asking if anyone's able to log
in without failing I was earlier because
he saw me playing but now we'll see
Dante is saying uh that he heard blood
Golem is going to be op
I imagine blood Golem's the one that's
going to like shed bodies so that you
can like corpse explode so
also like Neko is supposed to have
um I didn't I didn't see it and I don't
know if it's because of like a level cap
thing I should know this probably but
like um
there's like additional skill things
that you can pick for necro uh where
like it changes how your necro plays
like you can go
I think like a more like a summon list
necro where like you make trade-offs
basically it's like if you don't have
this summon then you get this kind of
thing
um
yeah first day of early beta was was a
nightmare
um
the rest of the weekend work perfectly
yep Deku that's right plus Ultra it was
Saturday Sunday was like pretty smooth
sailing like felt really like like not a
problem Friday Friday like nine
a.m when it started to like
at least I think 9 to 12 was pretty
rough so like we played like about half
an hour on Friday last week got booted
was it about a 45 minute Q got back in
meaning we got to play for another hour
and a half to two hours after that
before I got kicked again and that's
where I stopped
so for me luckily last week I got to
play about two hours in the first
three three and a half but I got booted
twice in that span
so
or network disconnect whatever I didn't
get booted but like you know I got the
network disconnect and what's
interesting is that Network disconnects
you to the um
the network disconnects you to the
character select screen making you think
like oh there's a chance to get back in
but even if you try from there at least
from The Limited times I tried it never
worked I always had to log out and log
back in
Deku this season's been really good if
y'all don't want I watch anime if y'all
don't watch anime my hero Academia is a
good one
um this season's been pretty pretty
amazing
uh dragon Ryu making the point that to
be honest the level scaling kills the
game for me after unlocking every
ability leveling will only make enemies
stronger and this just makes progression
non-existent no like
um
I I think it's fine personally because
like you're gonna get more and more gear
and more and more skills over time and
those monsters even though they're at
level like you start to melt them if I
could show you my level 25 you'll you'll
see that you start to like melt them
pretty pretty badly
um
uh Andre you just just be patient you'll
get there
um or like I said if if folks are or
don't want to sit through these early
cues right now I know there's eagerness
to play the game if you don't want to
sit through the queue just don't right
now like play later come back in like
three hours or something and it'll be
it'll be a lot I wouldn't say a lot
smoother but it'll probably be smoother
although open Beta take it with grain of
salt I'm just basing this off last week
Dante fell off my uh my hero yeah well
you got a lot to catch up on it
depending on where you stopped
um
I'm gonna play necro now and my God it's
sick Kevin skelly's all around me nice
Curtis yeah the skeletons like I said
they look
good
um funny enough like you know you fight
the skeletons in the game and you're
like oh they just look like common
normal
run-of-the-mill skeletons but look at
mine look at mine black sand don't you
dare don't you dare
compare Anthem and Diablo
Anthem didn't make it man
I wanted that game to make it I I it was
I had fun yeah but this is also coming
from like a I play a lot of Destiny or I
played a lot of Destiny I play a little
bit now with lightfall but like I took a
break
um so I really want Anthem to be cool
like the whole like I'm a mecha guy
right so like Gundam all that stuff so
like to me I'm like oh this is great
like you know you have like a suit slash
Iron Man suit slash like Mech armor that
you're wearing
and then I get to loot and and you know
action plus loot yeah I'm all in sign me
up you know
oh my God Joey Yee ye Jesus how you
doing Joey it's been a minute
hope you're doing well hope your
family's doing well
come on please okay
I hope that the one minute thing is true
and then I hope that we don't get failed
login like everyone else
uh I'm looking forward to armored Core
as well back then
um yes Slayer I'm looking forward to
armor core
um
I believe
you know as much hate as fortnite gets
fortnite's done some some things man and
some cool things like their big events
they're just like really awesome the
collabs are really cool
um and if you guys watched any of the
state of unreal this week
and their new fortnite uh Creator 2.0
it looks pretty good like the new engine
and like you know the little demo that
they ran where they're basically doing
like a PVE scenario I was like
you know people want to crap on this
game but
uh it looked pretty good you know and I
can only imagine what creators are gonna
make
you know it's out in the wild like
there's gonna be some experiences I feel
like all right
go I'm putting up the Goku Spirit energy
oh
my uh 25 Rogue was melting stuff too but
it's because it's like fully legendary
geared come on
no we'll be back for two minutes okay
two minutes is nothing two minutes is
nothing it didn't it didn't do like cute
for 48.
yeah slayer that it that I could see
that knock but I mean
we'll see we'll see
oh come on man what a what a debate we
got teased right there
uh it's okay we didn't fail though
that's the most important we didn't fail
login right so now I get a nice till day
two minutes though like who who knows
what that really means is it actually
two minutes
oh man
well happy Friday y'all I hope I hope
everyone's having a great Friday I hope
the folks that are in that are playing
are enjoying it and I hope the people
that are in queue like me are just
patiently waiting
um and excited to play
Ultron gave up after waiting an hour no
don't I was gonna say like if you've
waited an hour you might as well stick
it through because you've waited an hour
right that's that's my perception if you
saw the one hour and you're just like
nope and you got out that makes sense
but like if you waited the hour I would
have just said like please just a couple
more minutes wait it out
super psych just made it in right before
you nice this we got in earlier super
psych and we were playing until about
level five about 20 30 minutes and we
got we got Network disconnected
Lily is just running behind all right
but but we just saw her her
I don't know Muhammad I think people
care about Graphics in fortnite like
even the the the last change that they
made to and kind of enhance it a little
bit made a big difference if you just
compare like that to like you know the
beginning days it's
different
oh no a Gob says I was in but crashed
didn't have to wait an hour again yeah
that's the one I dread the most is um
getting booted and having to get back
into queue
not to character screen yet but hopeful
nothing's there until we're actually in
the game
okay
we're on veteran
entering the game making myself
disappear
oh there's a cue to get into the game
too
you can do it I believe I'm too scared
to hit cancel okay all right we're
getting our all right we are skipping
any dialogue we're getting our quests
and getting the hell out of town we're
getting the hell out of town okay
not in the game yet we're gonna try to
make it in the game
okay all right we need to we need to get
these quests like now
oh but then we should get gear we can
make this so much easier for actually
you know what I'm not I'm just not gonna
grab gear I'm not even gonna do it what
did you run I'm off to the dry steps
yeah just you go to the dry steps that's
fine
you go do that cloudy I gotta get your s
your spear that you sold to this guy
because he had no money and I have to
buy it for you
yeah yeah I'm skipping dialogue I'm
sorry
give me the amulet too all right
we got we gotta get we gotta get at it
don't skip story I'm sorry Muhammad this
part's not that important I can tell you
what's happening so like
warrath is gonna go explore the dry
steps where the other bad guy person's
going we're gonna do some stuff over
here and and clean things up
ancient orders Scholars and ages I'm
just too scared to be in Talent man
these days we are few in number
there is another haradron all right he's
gonna look for donnen
sorry skip battle to the school's gone
he's gonna go to schools win where we
can't even we can't even go there right
now because the beta doesn't happen you
can just
be careful all right he's gonna go dry
steps we're skipping this
our yes I know thank you
I know the game comes out the sixth
oh we got rare boots oh we just rubber
banded that's okay
it's okay that's okay
oh there's a little side quest here uh
did we grab it I guess we grab it right
you guys want me to make the character
Opie
or should I just play it through normal
you don't need to pay the pay that
Philip to play it's open
to you see or rocky sorry if I butchered
the name apologies
uh
gotta go do that cheer stuff
the worst part is playing this five
times in a row hey man it's okay that's
why you skip after the SEC this uh on
your second run
the new militia
training night and day yes
all right she basically wants me to
learn how to emote and um oops
and we need a cheer for them so
[Music]
yep all right we're gonna cheer that was
not too bad slow cap slow clap
okay
cool thanks
I hope they don't get oh so you don't
want to boost their morale but I have to
roll some gear
you want me to grab gear I have a bunch
of gear in my in my stash
that I would it will make it
exponentially faster but that's
if you guys care about that or not
um
I don't
describe legendaries I can wear oh I
don't but I have the shield
oh I can't even equip it because I have
a two-handed staff oh we got some rings
though
uh
I'm sure
I don't know it doesn't matter
anything's better than nothing right now
we're gonna roll through it we got look
I have a dagger that does 148 damage
compared to that
all right we're just gonna we're just
gonna blow everything off
let's just go easy mode yeah here I'll
I'll pick that staff back up all right
that's good enough
the battle pass is uh supposed to be all
aesthetic
[Music]
shouldn't be paid a win
I know a lot of people are concerned
about that but don't skip story okay
well
I will not skip the story here but you
all have to hope that nothing happens
because look we're rubber banding just
trying to get to the to the oh no
not like this okay it needed to load in
the people okay
we can we can make it through this story
right
children of darkness no don't restart it
here in Q already do not do not restart
again it will make things worse and face
walk in the light
all right I'm not skipping stories
against sin brother we're asking for
trouble like my friend's mother let the
light of anarius burn away wickedness
let not Temptation lead you from his
holy iridiums let righteousness sear
away corruption and sin cast out thy
Darkness for only light must remain cast
out thine Darkness for only light must
remain
from the West
yes reverent mother
Laura's not a company
sent me on without him
putting faith in that old man was a
mistake what could possibly be of
Greater import
Lilith
so you know
hmm
we have received word from one of our
Knights the demon sighting in Gale
Valley
scription matches too closely to the
sighting invest
if you would travel to your lesson and
take stock of the events there
you would have the Gratitude of the
Cathedral of light
I had thought to send Laura but again he
fails in his duty
with or without forearth
the will of an audience shall be done
[Music]
here take the knights report before you
go
okay
Reverend mother I received a report of a
potential demon sighting horned woman
near yelesna mines
performed routine inspection nothing yet
sent in Priest and escort of knights
will report in when we find something
[Music]
the only time I think you could play
Diablo 3 offline was was it console
D3 I think
very cool if you could do that
um for PC though
I mean I never did I guess so
you're probably gonna melt things let us
out okay I gotta stop running
that's just gonna cause more problems
probably
okay we made it to the next tree do we
have corpse explode let's go
let's go let me no let me out
I just want to leave the town
nope
Thou shalt not pass
okay
how did that how did that other
character how did that Barbarian or
Druid make it through
okay no
this is not so great all right try again
okay is there a way around I could go
all the way around I'm gonna try going
from the bottom
okay that okay that person's that's very
weird
uh so this is what I meant by you can
like invite to party you just
walk next to someone and then
uh necro and Druid are in this beta an
open beta
this did not happen last week where I
couldn't like walk out of town by the
way
if anyone was curious
[Music]
it's all right there's multiple exits
they can't they can't stop me they can't
hold me down for too long
we'll just we'll just go all the way
around
it's no problem
okay I almost thought they were gonna be
like no actually you can't go around
food
give me those give me that leather
all right we can yeah we're gonna go
around that's fine
just like we drew it up we wanted to go
sightseeing anyways
corpse explode pretty big
[Applause]
uh of course
but also very satisfied
and I'm not gonna complain about that
I would say Slayer you just gotta wait
it out what is this oh you guys want to
see the new conduit shrine
you basically get to teleport around
let's go do this dungeon real quick
uh same areas Joe nothing different
between closed and open Beta outside of
being able to play the necro and the and
the druid
oh I don't have conduit anymore that's
kind of a shame I thought I could roll
that into here
[Applause]
oh we actually lost skeletons
um this is all right you know what this
is kind of too easy
we're gonna take that stuff we're gonna
take the stuff off
it's probably not fun for you guys to
watch that
what was that lightning form it's a
conduit Shrine
um so instead of like emitting lightning
from your body like D3 you turn into
like um
a ball of lightning and then you can
like kind of like warp towards the
enemies
I'm going back to the the gear we picked
up so we'll just play it like
it's pretty straight laced
it's it's still very strong so it's like
I don't there's not really any issue
regardless
[Applause]
corpse exploded very strong
probably need something to um create
bodies though if there isn't any um
oh increase the radius and then what
uh because of Darkness skill instead of
exploding releases vile miasma
interesting
deals 10 increased damage to enemies
that are slowed okay we can try the
miasma everybody doesn't explode anymore
now only four skeletons they've learned
it's not three anymore
it could be more
all right did we make it to the other
side of where we needed to go I think so
right
there's a lot of oh okay
maybe they just really don't want me to
go this way
let's go
corpse explode is very satisfying
like a lot of the skills have this like
like I don't know more like
meat and you can feel like the impact
like of the skill like audibly and like
kind of visually
hopefully we find some world events for
you guys to see
those are always fun what is it
oh there's also this dodge mechanic that
um
is in um the game that's kind of like
the roll from D3
[Music]
yeah they're definitely trying to to get
that um Diablo 2 audience you know but
I would say the closest things to that
is because of the um
the darker tones
maybe some of the skill tree Synergy
stuff but not really
uh
and then it's it's hard to say too
without seeing the Paragon
um board how like that will advance and
change the game as well
you had to sword more damage
[Music]
[Applause]
I actually don't know where we're going
but it doesn't really matter I mean we
could do Mainline quests or we could
choose size quests
[Music]
let's try the miasma thing instead of
explosions might be a mistake but
we're here to experiment right
here's a little bit before you get the
um
[Applause]
oh also if you get to level 20 you get
the uh wolf uh wolf code backpack
uh
I don't know if that means better
you guys
these also using them
all right
there's a murmuring apples
bubbles
oh wow we're already jumping 40 damage
okay hey how come his skeletons have
shields
oh here you go
so we can pick
and upgrade our guys a skirmisher or
Defenders let's just we can have one
additional
[Applause]
what does this do
oh I can either have one more or when
they crit
[Music]
anytime you critically strike um yeah
sure
or you go no skeletons and we have more
crit chance but I think because we
okay yeah
okay
I think because we uh
we are not as strong now we probably
wanna
hold off on the they're giving us
but that's what I meant you can
sacrifice something to get something
else pretty much
yeah that one you're right I think Dante
like that that was pretty easy for a
necro just because I think anything
ranged is probably gonna be easy but um
oh is this gonna send me into that
dungeon I think
foreign
I haven't much time
yeah I bring back the ears
is filled in the ancient city beneath
the mountain
we carried his body to the usury but
he arose
thirsting for blood
oh they are escaped please
you must see him
[Music]
um
and then yeah all right we'll do this
dungeon since we're here and then we're
gonna go down to do the main story after
that
thank you yeah it's pretty fun
the beta does end on Monday 12 p.m
Pacific uh they give you a I think last
week I
some someone told me they were in until
almost one until they actually finally
got booted or maybe like 12 45.
the ACT is
well it depends if you do everything or
not
um I think it someone was saying like I
think around level 25 might be eight
hours
and there's a lot of side quests there's
like other world of answers three
strongholds for you to do and and finish
and the strongholds are like open area
type Dungeons and those are pretty fun
we can try to check out uh one of those
too but they're a little higher level I
think so I'd have to get to
at least double digits I think or maybe
it just scaled because it's like I think
it's two levels higher
than
um
your actual level I bet those don't
stack though it's the only downside
imagine corpse explode you can just you
know keep doing it
for the damage the big beeps
oh
thank you
and now we do the thing because
um something that people are not too
happy about is that the dungeons have
basically um
you gotta basically do some type of
batch quest to open the door to the boss
basically
that was a criticism only one
I have not tried out the S5 but I think
I know
it's pretty fun decent
hey
I don't know I like the cutscenes we got
to show you the anarius one I guess that
one's pretty good
there's more cutscenes though it's not
just like wait till you know end of act
or whatever it's
oh you know what I should put on the
toggle wheel just so that you guys can
see too is um
so you can do this and leave dungeon is
one of the things that's like you don't
have to click to the front
I'm guessing you could put like
teleport to town too maybe that's what
someone was saying earlier
maybe not
someone has to tell me later someone was
saying that would Joe was able to um
set something up where you could just
leave dungeon TP or TP come back to
dungeon or something I don't remember
what it was exactly but you can always
watch that video later
the zoom on PS5 is much closer oh really
closer than this
this is that's zoomed in PC
[Applause]
I think there's one more of these like
gate winch things
the other thing that they changed on
Console which is very nice is in D3 yeah
whenever you pop open the menu uh you
would have to stop right for your for
your partner to to do their inventory
stuff now they have it where
um I have new orders both of you both
players can abandon your post uh
effective immediately
as for your current duties
I know the stories let them rot in their
cages in darkness
they would not have lived like animals
perhaps we will teach them a lesson that
they're carrying into the next life
explode
I lost my skeleton skill
um it depends they still have not fixed
this from last week where I can't cross
here that that is still broken I have to
go around
uh PC you hit s and you should show your
skills
um
I want to say like
like PC you can drag and drop too I
think
why does that seem so strong
all right
it's kind of hard just seeing it though
sure we just take the armor I guess
oops
second gate wedge like boss
then we'll go do Mainline story and then
we'll try to get to this
made that
[Applause]
yeah so every class to my understanding
has some type of kind of um
extra set of skill type stuff and uh
oh you got Golem at 25 that's gonna take
forever well not forever it's gonna take
like another six hours or so
um meaning we probably won't get Golem
on this Golem Golem on the stream sorry
we'll get skeletal Mages probably
because we are what we are
level nine yeah we can probably get to
15. no problem
I still think corpse explode is more fun
than the miasma thing to be honest
oh
we got our first rare
gotta be worth using right well let me
see
huh do I not have a better
still slightly weaker
oh well we'll do it because I think it
will cast faster
and then you can also sacrifice your
skeletons like I said to get um passive
skills for the necro themselves so I
guess you could make your Necco just
the solo like strong Caster
not using Dodge
savings
[Music]
my bags are full
all right the sword is more damage
I cannot carry more
inventory problems here
[Applause]
my burden is too great
I think there's other things too and
options that I'm not that I need I
should toggle on like there's advanced
stuff I think that helps with some of
that
oh we gotta do another thing expected
no way this problem is not better oh
that looks cool
look at me
man maybe necro gets some of the cool
armor though huh
oh we have to kill everything that's
what it is whoops I should just read
this uh Journal instead
here I am too busy just like you know
nuking stuff how's the lag there's no
lag uh the closest thing I've had is
some rubber banding in certain parts but
other than that and the one time we got
disconnected to have to like log back in
we've been pretty good although I
probably just jinxed it open betas where
everyone res you can download it on your
platform uh either on PC or if you
Battlenet client or on console and then
um you can play it you can try all five
classes this week level cap is level 25.
I think they fixed a Shabba the world
boss to spawn at I think it's like 10
a.m 12 p.m 10 p.m and then 12 a.m Sunday
so four chances to fight it last week
um
when we beat it one time you get like
four-ish legendary drops plus you get a
weekly like Satchel thing that dropped
five more legendaries do I expect there
to be as many though during live I don't
know like it could just be like a beta
dropping more legendaries type scenario
so that people can get a feel for that
but um what you didn't see on my map is
when you beat dungeons you most dungeons
have codexes
and aspects and what you can do is you
can imprint an aspect on a weapon so we
can take a look at that because I last
week I unlocked all the aspects
and then we can imprint something on
like one of my weapons once I get like a
good decent rare weapon or I can just do
it anyways because it doesn't carry over
anyways I know on essence
[Applause]
all right
my bags are full
okay
you can use the this
[Music]
how did he get past the queue uh I
stayed in it and then I
raise my spirit energy fingers and then
I stayed in war cue got re-queued again
and then
here we are
there's probably more than half stuck
maybe uh block said zombie very possible
we'll play for as long as we can before
we get booted
um potentially
our level 10
we can make our we'll make our way down
there
um sorry that you got that Eric uh code
when you were almost past the queue some
people were saying that they failed
their Q2 and had to get back in queue
which is
not ideal
um I guess we just lucked out because if
that happened to us we probably would
have just called it the stream because
it would have taken probably another 40
minutes to get back into something but
my cue when I got kicked was not that
long was like probably 25 minutes
I mean you can still kind of spam
potions because it's only on like a two
second timer the quest the thing is you
only get five well not just five you get
x amount of potions depending on how you
upgrade it and or also from your um
from their Renown so like this one gives
you an extra potion charge
we could do this one because it's a
quest it's a this dungeon
side quest
so many people are asking for refunds
hey I mean it all that's totally their
choice an option they definitely spent
the money to buy it so you know if they
want that they can do that
um but also this one you know made open
bid is free so
try to get in have fun play it
give me my suggestion
you created a character and got an error
code oh man I'm sorry
this time around I took a pre-made
because I just wanted to get in to the
prey and you know we're gonna lose it
we're gonna lose everything after this
weekend so
you like Poe blast better I I um I think
Poe has done some great stuff
and uh I do agree I I like their um
their flasks because they have like
multiple classes and then they have
different properties and you have to
like you know kill things to get you
know potion back you kind of have to
kill things to get posted back here too
but there's more you there's more
um
things to play around with there
um compared to like what we have here
there are elixirs in this game where you
have to craft them they're not like
something that like you know
you just have you know that you can loot
but could you imagine having more things
to have to um
grind for
that guys
[Applause]
oh
heeled
when I died in that forsaken place it
was without the grace of delight
clear path to Salvation
foreign
this is not as satisfying as like normal
perfect smoke because I would have
spammed I would have spammed it by now
you would have heard all the like
explosions
all right
oh my back's the first legendary y'all
see what does it do when hit well not
healthy a magical bubble is someone
around you for five seconds okay we'll
get a mute sick okay sure
first legendary
[Music]
um
it should get better over the weekend I
imagine
um it did last weekend first the Friday
was pretty pretty tough though
it's been better though I will say at
least my personal experience has been
better
um because when we got kicked out this
time the key was only about 25 minutes
with that extra two minute queue whereas
last week when I got bumped it was about
48 minutes so I think there's been
progress made
um but that's your mileage may vary
because I also you know some people in
China have gotten that kind of like
login disconnect type issue which I did
not have so I've been fortunate since
all right we got enough for the open the
door
all right let's um
you know we'll finish this one out and
then we'll swap we'll swap the uh
the skills
kind of curious what some of the um
necro legendaries do because they
they're there's like usually some type
of skill based type thing that like
changes one of your skills or how you
use one of those skills or enhances a
skill so
I was hoping that we would get something
like that had a cooler effect than just
giving me a bubble but
survivability is important too
yeah you get a little puppy in a bag if
you hit Level 20.
there's a bubble from The Shield we
don't get hurt in here it's pretty good
for the world boss too in a way if we
need it
you actually get that legendary effect
from an amulet later
um
okay take it rear dagger
I think so
I really want you guys to see oh nope
okay we got the item we need
you've been accused since release yikes
uh we've gotten in twice since um or at
least
this guy you want to be careful he has
like a
oh like a big rag that one that grab
right there you don't want to get hit by
that
um
I have no corpses to put near him though
as I say don't get hit by that I got hit
by it but the shield has carried me
we got a new chest my bags are full
impressive that's not what I meant to do
is the game online only uh tomorrow yes
[Music]
all right let's uh let's Reef so you can
refund your skills pretty easily it's
gold I think as you get higher up level
wise it costs a little bit more but
all right bursts and enemies blood
let's just do some blood stuff I guess
when I after picking up a blood orb your
next Hemorrhage also deals damage to
enemies
there
fortify
we're gonna go for the deeps um what did
we just use just now we did bloodlance
we're gonna do blood surge
is this like a hold down ability though
I know I'm never a huge fan of those
let's just try it
[Music]
fortified
we're still using corpse explode though
there's no way we're not
we're just gonna do the
non-miasma version
although we have nothing to slow them
though is the only thing
[Music]
we unlocked another tree but now we can
curse
Iron Maiden classic oh there's a
decrepify
there's the slow into the explode so we
need one more Point huh
or I guess what I could have did was it
three and one and then one that's fine
we'll let alone well what level I'll get
there
um that little red sign
is
that little uh red sign Red Skull on the
map is um that's a stronghold we can see
if we can do it
wow
that is uh pretty cool all right
they're dying too fast
[Music]
how can I reassign the Book of the Dead
skill
um on PC I'll show you you just go to
the um
your character screen and you can kind
of pick your stuff scope nothing I love
your vids thanks I don't make that many
actually funny enough last live stream
was the last one I was on so I
appreciate that if you if you really
know
um so you go to character at least
that's how I did it the Book of the Dead
I picked skirmisher where I crit they
crit more you could also pick Defenders
if you want and then there's I guess
Reapers at level 12 which we're almost
about to get to so we could check that
out in a second check out the Reapers
uh everything there okay
we're not even using corpse explode this
other ability is so good though or it
feels good
sorry y'all give me one second
foreign
[Music]
we'll see if
let's see if it scales I have to imagine
yes it'll probably be like what it'll do
I think is like if I'm 11 it should be
13 I think
oh it's level 15.
how about that
why not even come on
are you not gonna let me in you all
right
[Applause]
let's get to 13.
let me get to 13 and I'll come back now
the boss is kind of the boss is kind of
hard
um especially because we need
bodies to do damage he's probably gonna
wreck the skeletons
um
give it a go nah I I refute what I said
I'll be back there in a little bit
[Applause]
maybe that skill doesn't go well with
corpse exploding
whoa 60 minutes so 156 that doesn't
sound so great
sorry uh y'all are having problems and
issues though that sounds not so great
it's I guess this is not a true dungeon
you can't just do the lead dungeon
the ass Lair I don't know why it's
kicking you and then having you re-log
into queue that sounds not so great
bloodmaster yeah I don't know man
bloodmaster is pretty fun that blood
Miss skill could be good but it looks
more like a like an escape because it
said like your movement speed gets
slowed but you're immune
so I'm not really sure what to make of
that one right now and then
there's no other blood skill here the
next big skills are down here I think
which I've never seen these ones oh
there's bone spirit
and then here's like ultimate skills
that are like on a way longer cooldown
next Hemorrhage it's in an area very
nice
that is like a big that's a story Quest
that we're not on yet
but we can make our way down here
because there's story quests to do for
sure
I can show you the one fun like kind of
like I think it's like a Hellraiser
reference or something a subtle Hill
razor reference Quest type thing
I'm not even getting to use Corpus
all right let's let's get it big let's
get a big nice big density
yeah that seems pretty good that's
corpse explode by the way that wasn't
even a blood surge I think blood surge
probably did the same I imagine but
ah sorry Black Knight that you got
kicked after 30 minutes of playing
what kind of happened to us too
all right we hit Level 12. that's nice
um we can do
we can do decrepify
curse them
curse on them Corps explode for more
damage but you probably don't even need
that Synergy at this point
no get this Waypoint
go back and forth pick up some side
quests do the main story the next main
story be see how far
tonight
lead towards a strange Light in the
Forest
been gone all night
I think it's time I went after him but
the forest is dangerous
would you accompany me
and then certain boots have different
mechanics so some have like I don't know
it's not on these ones but like they'll
have like another evade or like move
faster they steady supply of shall we
say uh soaring no problem definitely not
me from Game Spot that's uh Max
Blumenthal who's the breath of the wild
expert I'm happy that he helped you
learn how to win bomb I require a host
he's got a bunch of Tricks a bunch of
things he still does the everything he
didn't know or things you didn't know
still like once a month there's got a
lot of cool stuff a lot of cool
technology animated with only a few
drops of blood
Adventure out and retrieve this myself
but I'm more accustomed to dealing with
the fully dead
your discretion is appreciated of course
and you will be rewarded oh I wonder if
[Music]
I say like I wonder how this is going to
be if it's gonna work on deck or not
it's in deck is that what do you need
dangerous although I guess you need a
connection though but man that's you I
enjoyed playing D3 on switch because
like you could just play anywhere it's
about the demon woman all week
vigo's gone looking into her claims he
should be at the mining camp north of
here
or less Court of knights went missing
their last week
along with the girls the connection
stuff is server stuff though they like
will ramp a little bit before a launch
but they don't truly like get more right
they just kind of do their best to load
manage because like you think about wow
expansions they are always
like littered with day one day two type
um issues
[Music]
why are you telling me there's a quest
here
that's really weird
I found that
I just talked to him
I'm sure that was scary all right I
don't know I don't know why it's showing
me that
oh you know what we should do is get rid
of all this junk in her
he can take what's left
[Music]
what is this is this any good oh wow
it's way more damage than the shield and
we don't we don't need that
invincibility right now I don't think
although it does reduce acid cost
I don't know that seems yeah we don't
even have anything that needs to cool
down there's so much more damage I think
we go with the damage
oh that's
I swear last week it was maybe but I
could have sworn
yeah it's like where you um
you pick up one it would pick up the
like nearby ones but I guess
or I just have a memory
we are clicking everyone right now
uh here we'll do a quick side quest real
quick so you can see the the little
thing I was talking about
figure out where this her wife's husband
is at
I want to do that
no not like this
all right well chat
uh this this could be a problem
I'm pretty sure this is not gonna work
I'm gonna try it one time just in case
because we're here yep okay now we're
gonna
exit Diablo
and then we're gonna try to get back in
and then we're gonna look at the queue
and then depending on the Queue we might
just have to
call it a stream because it just really
depends on
depends on uh how long the queue is we
are expecting a separately high volume
during the open Beta login Q times may
be longer during Peak play times this
weekend is the error or not error
message but the critical message from
blizzard uh we'll see how long the queue
is last time we hopped back in it was
20.
that's maybe okay but like anything else
there's okay
59 I don't think I don't think we're
gonna stay around for 59 minutes
um this week
realistically unfortunately I'm glad you
guys got to see a little bit of the The
Necromancer the corpse explodes some of
the kind of like Book of the Dead stuff
with the with the necro
um sorry
uh these cues you know I I kind of
expected this that open Beta was gonna
be even tougher because there's just so
many more people playing or trying to
play this week uh my advice like I said
earlier if you're trying to play
I would say go wait it out couple hours
let let things kind of settle let the
dust settle a little bit and then try
again
maybe like in a couple hours two three
hours or if you're in queue and you just
want to like do something on the side
come back to it then play that way like
that's what I do maybe go
you know uh watch watch some shows or
some anime or whatever or like go read a
book or something and then come back
um later check on it because yeah this
this ain't happening right now and it's
it's even giving you the estimated 59
minutes so it could be longer I know
some folks in chat are also having the
struggles of just um
you know getting finally through and
then getting kicked out again so
hopefully that gets resolved for y'all
but um really appreciate everyone
spending the time today to check out the
Necromancer again glad we got to play a
little bit showcase some other stuff
wanted to show off more obviously but
um you know maybe we'll get higher level
maybe we just put something up over the
weekend some gameplay or something to
show off some higher level stuff maybe
some more legendaries some legendary
effects
um but you know stay tuned to Gamespot
uh in the future we'll we'll do more
Diablo for sure when the release comes
out anything that we can do before that
we'll do uh there's a bunch of guides on
our website if you want to you know if
you're if you're a beginner some people
are saying beginner there's a bunch of
different guides on the site that uh
tell you like you know good builds for
certain classes uh there's galleries
that show like a bunch of the legendary
items if you want to see some of those
that are in the beta at least and yeah
like that's really it really appreciate
everyone this week
um have a great rest of your Friday and
have a great weekend and uh we'll see
you next time uh
thanks again I'm gonna go to this other
screen
bye
[Music]